exchange
the exchange is a place where you can
post requests asking members and tutors
for various services including
translation writing correction
pronunciation correction and more
choose the type of request you would
like to make
then click post
each time a response is posted to your
request by a member you will receive a
notification
you will be able to decide how many
points you want to award and to whom
should you be interested you can earn
points by responding to requests from
other members on the exchange
profile
your profile shows your learning
activities and statistics your
description and your activity feed
communicate with other members by
posting on their walls
you can edit your profile information on
the settings page
link avatar your avatar is a graphical
representation of your progress in your
new language
earn avatar credits when you create
links
click on your avatar to go to the avatar
store to purchase artifacts with your
avatar credits
speak
on the speak page you will find a list
of tutors who offer conversations in
your target language
tutors can post one-on-one conversations
or group conversations
you can also find tutors through the
find a tutor page
you can request specific conversation
times
discussions on link take place through
skype and you will receive a detailed
conversation report after every
conversation
tutoring
to tutor go to the teach page to learn
about how to do this
you will post discussion times in your
time zone other members will see these
in their time zone you will receive a
notification when someone signs up
as a conversation host you are required
to fill out a conversation report with
corrections suggestions and comments
after your conversation you must submit
this report to the learner in order to
receive your points